Speaker 1: All right, so as we talked about
earlier, we just had the 20th anniversary
of 9/11.
We talked a little bit about the George W.
Bush speech on the 20th anniversary.
There were a number of different events with
multiple former presidents commemorating the
20 year anniversary of the 9/11 attacks.
I've told my story of where I was on 9/11.
Many times I was sitting in my morning psychology
class in high school and a known troublemaker
came back from wandering the halls and said,
we're under attack.
And our teacher, the late, great Mr. Donald
Palmisano, told him, you've caused enough
trouble today.
I'm sure everything's fine.
Sit down.
And we quickly learned not everything was
fine.
Mr. Palmisano ended up apologizing to that
student when we were ultimately back in class
and said, you were right and I was wrong.
So on Saturday, the 20th anniversary of 9/11,
President Biden, Obama, Bush and Clinton all
attended and spoke at various events and commemorations.
Trump didn't go to any of that stuff.
He later stopped by Ground Zero, sort of close
by and took some pictures with firefighters,
didn't go to the actual events.
But what Donald Trump did do on the 20th anniversary
of 9/11 is boxing commentary.
I'm not kidding.
As I posted to Twitter on Saturday, tongue
in cheek, of course, a sober commemoration
of 9/11 by a former president.
This was promoted for a while.
President Trump hosts the most anticipated
heavyweight fight of the year on the 20th
anniversary of 9/11, Holyfield versus Belfort.
I was shocked by this.
Also, since Holyfield is almost 60 years old,
I didn't realize that this was so anticipated,
but OK.
And it was promoted as having full live in-person
commentary by President Trump.
Apparently it was Trump and Donald Trump Jr..
And how many layers are there to this stuff?
Not only is a former president doing boxing
commentary on the 20th anniversary of 9/11,
not only is he doing it with his doofus son,
but the son even sort of turns it into a grift,
which you'll hear in this clip.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: We're here at Hardrock in
Speaker 1: Florida, by the way.
The audio is you just you can barely even
hear Trump.
I have a great time.
Speaker 2: What a great champion to them.
They're going to be having a good time.
I wouldn't want to do a lot of people wouldn't
want to do this.
They look like they're going to have a good
time.
Speaker 1: No, the fighters, the desperation
from Don Jr. to be liked by his dad and the
stupid forced laughs at every dumb joke.
It's almost sad.
Speaker 2: They love doing so.
Why she there a teacher there one year, Anderson,
so, you know, if you can have some fun tonight,
guys, I think this is going to be a lot of
levity at the end of a rather somber day.
I have a
Speaker 1: little bit of a somber levity at
the end of a somber day.
And don't forget
Speaker 2: to shoot me your questions.
I may have to finally twist his arm a little
bit to find out about Area 51 and the aliens
or whatever else you may want to ask about.
Speaker 1: So you know what this is?
He was doing this grift all day, Don Jr..
This was a pay per view event.
And so Don Jr. was teasing.
You know, I'm going to take questions and
maybe some of the questions will be about
the truth, about aliens.
What does Trump know about aliens?
Because he's the president and he was told
all sorts of stuff.
It's all a grift.
In the end, they will do anything for a buck
and or for publicity.
Speaker 2: We're going to have some fun at
the end of a somber day, and I'm just looking
forward to it.
Some of the great white legends are here,
guys.
You can check it out on any cable network
or fight TV.
Tune in now.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's just nothing.
There is nothing that isn't a grift with these
people.
Let's look at some of the actual commentary
just to be thorough.
And it's like then they start explaining to
Trump, sir, people are chanting your name
and it's just all so weird.
This was the 20th anniversary of 9/11.
Is a former president OK?
If Obama had done boxing commentary on the
20th anniversary of 9/11, it would be 24/7
coverage for three days on Fox News about
how anti-American Obama is.
Speaker 2: Here we go.
That was a fantastic job by a really great
young man.
He's got a big future and we're just honored.
Thank you,
Unidentified: Chad.
That's what everybody is saying here, that
everybody's screaming right now.
Here.
People are going nuts.
Speaker 2: This is a main event.
Speaker 1: So you think trumps at all embarrassed
that where he's going now for this is where
he's doing boxing commentary like this is
the stage on which he now appears.
Unidentified: Thank you much.
What an amazing rendition of the national
anthem.
Speaker 2: Thank you very much, everybody.
Thank you.
This is an honor to be with you and what a
great evening.
And I think you're going to see an incredible
fight and.
It's great.
Junior, it's great to be with you guys and
champions.
We love you men, special people, special warriors.
Speaker 1: I don't feel I feel like I live
in a different country than where this environment
is going on, like it's almost surreal that
this is where this is what one former president
was doing on 9/11,
Unidentified: still going strong.
Speaker 2: That's where they got the jet going
that's been going around stadiums in college
football.
Speaker 1: The last couple of days, there's
Don Junior.
Is there something sad and pathetic about
Don Junior having to come in there?
Yep, this is the same chant that all the the
people in stadiums have been doing.
It's a degree of please love me, dad.
That actually makes me sad for Don Jr. in
a way as well.
Speaker 2: It's a great honor.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, everybody, very much.
We love our country and love our country.
Thank you very much.
So we're going to see a great fight tonight.
And we've seen some good ones.
That last one we're going to call.
I think he's going to be shown.
That was you think it's going to be so we're
going to be calling him very accurately.
I think this is going to be a you're right,
because the future is very explosive.
Yes, he is.
So, you know, are
Speaker 1: they even at the venue?
Like, it almost seems like Trump's not even
at the venue.
It's something about this is all very weird
Speaker 2: and two warriors are going to go
for that.
That's not going well for them.
Very exciting, isn't it, House, very exciting,
no, two great fighters.
One's a boxer, though, the others.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
All right.
So there's Trump's analysis.
The up this is just embarrassing.
And again, the world's laughing at all of
it.
And it's just what are people thinking?
What are people thinking?
One other little aspect of this that I did
want to touch on, which starts to actually
go over the line into the politically absurd.
And let's talk about
that next.